good evening and welcome to this meeting
traffic council's planning and devel
management committee my name is
councelor L Stanley Chair of this
committee before we start the meeting
proper can I ask if anybody present
intends to photograph Bill the the
meeting okay thank you in any event we
all been recorded for live and subse
broadcast on the council's YouTube
channel continuing on to my right is
Council Walsh who Vice chair of this
committee to our left and right of
council officers from planning NE and
highways down both sides of the
table our members of the committee who
are all local counselors I will
introduce their us this week to the
agenda item one attendances to note our
attendance if we just have and any
apologies uh we have one apology this
evening from councelor Michael
Tay item two Declarations of Interest
members to give notice many person
personal or prejudicial interest and the
nature of that interest relating to any
item on the agenda in accordance with
the adopted code of Comm does any member
wish to declare an
interest okay thank you members item
three minutes to receive it so deter to
approve a correct record for the
administer of the meeting held on 12th
of October
second thank you members I four
questions for members of the public we
have received a list of question
questions concerning one of the
developments on the agenda this evening
and ask m co to explain how they will be
addressed under that planning rules exp
thank you chair um yes we received a
question which was in uh in relation to
the Shore Road application which is the
first application on the agenda this
evening um that was a representation uh
in respect of that application needs to
be treated as such uh and their thought
needs to be considered with the planing
application at the same time uh with we
can't split the consideration of that
application between qu between questions
between the debate so that uh
representation has been um reported in
the additional information report which
is before members this evening responded
to by officers in there of course we can
take it if members have any PRS about
the content of that report they can make
that uh um but that rather than taking
that as a question that is how it be
with thank you Mr I five addition
information report to consider report of
the head of Planning and Development to
be tabled after the meeting has been so
Ted and as permit C explanation of the
last item the answers to the emailed
questions can be found in that
report item six applications commission
to develop to consider the T report of
the head of planning and development for
the following applications we have three
on the agenda tonight the process is the
same in each case the item was
introduced by a member compy if we have
speakers on that item they then speak
next me get three minutes Ward members
get five minutes I'll then open the item
Up For Debate to members of the
committee only and we let on to decision
by majority vote the first item on the
agenda is
11688 land offshore Road in arston it's
on page one of the park now miss L will
give the introduction thank you Miss
Lo thank you
chair this application relates to land
at Shore Road and is currently accessed
off pennybridge Lane planning permission
is sought for the erection of 12 one
bedroom dwellings available for social
rent the scheme would Solly provide
accommodation to support people out of
homelessness and rough
sleeping members will recall that this
application was originally brought to
the planning committee in August 2023
earlier this year and members resolved
to defer the application to enable
officers to to seek further design
improvements Amendments of sub
subsequently May been
made and by the applicant um which
involve the reciting of the development
9.5 m f to the South away from sh
properties and this allows the increase
of the communal amenity space for the
development further changes to the
elevations have have taken place along
with changes to the boundary treatment
and Landscaping along with all the
ground floor units now being compliant
with
m42 accessible and adaptable dwellings
of the building regulations I'll go
through the the changes and the
amendments in more detail as we go
further into the um into the
presentation just as a reminder and the
site is an open piece of land which is
currently used informally as car parking
adjacent to the Terrace properties on sh
view to the north sh view Residential
Care Home is to the East and um Trafford
FC is to the South Beyond Shore
Road so a couple of photographs to show
you the application site and its
relationship with a um sh View and so
you can see here it's the the open space
the site and with the Terrace um to the
north this is a view of the Shore View
Terrace
properties uh this Photograph shows you
um from Penny Lane looking into the to
the application site the informal car
parking and the Terrace in the
background you can also see the
Landscaping along the boundary with the
the care home
site this photograph shows you you from
within the care home site looking
towards the application site and and the
existing trees that sit on that boundary
and again this this one just shows you
further around the site and and the side
elevation of the care
home so the application is reported to
committee because six or more
representations contrary to officer
recommendation have been received and
the application Lin is in the council's
ownership so the main amendments to the
scheme that was previously presented to
to committee relate to the reciting of
the development
um the development is cited 9.5 M
further south um enlarging the
application site and creating a greater
distance between those front elevations
of the properties on Shore View and the
proposed development the layers in the
design of the building remains unchanged
but those separation dist distance
increase and so we now have 24.5 M
between the twostory side Gable and the
front elevation of the the Terrace
properties and 21 M between the single
story element and the front
elevation there's 7.5 M between the the
the boundary edge of the site and the U
the Terrace properties as was previously
um as as in the previous application
I'll just bring up the previous scheme
here so you can see where the previous
scheme was cited much closer to to the
Residential Properties on Shore View we
had 15 M between the front elevation and
the twostory side Gable and 11.5 me
between front elevation and the single
story element there just the um table
that's taken out of the report so you
can clearly see those those changes in
dimensions and that increase in
separation distance that's been achieved
through the Amendments so talked through
these before but an overall reciting of
that development 9.5 meters further
south so overall the proposed building
Remains Two stories in a scale
constructed in facing brick with
elements of Comm and private amenity
space tree planting and Landscaping is
proposed around the site with a brick
wall proposed to the western and
southern boundaries there's some very
slight changes to the elevational
treatment that's been sought through
this through these changes and that just
adds a little bit more repetition in
terms of the windows their position and
sizing so if we just have a little look
at the those Landscaping plan again this
shows the increased separation distance
from the the Terrace properties on Shore
View and the consequence of that is this
increased level of communal amenity
space that will be afforded to the to
the future occupiers of the development
and that's a positive to the scheme also
further change is in the boundary
treatment along this the the northern
boundary with the properties on ter and
Shore Terrace Shore View sorry um
previously it was proposed to be a brick
wall with some planting alongside that
that's now changed to an 0.9 M High to
the pickup fence with low level
hedging 17 trees overall will be planted
within the development and that's an
increase of five from the previous
scheme and we also see and to the
Northern parts of the site along the
boundary and more of the the existing
trees retained and adjacent to
shio so while it's recognized that the
development will result in a loss of
some trees Landscaping is proposed on
all the boundaries of the site and in
the form of tree plan and hedging to
mitigate for that loss the Landscaping
plan shows a very strong tree line with
hedging along the western boundary
hedging along the northern boundary with
Shore View and some planting and hedging
on the southern
boundary the representations received
throughout through throughout this
application process including a fair the
further consultation on amended plans
largely cited the loss of car parking
within the area and the impact on
residential amenity the site and the
remainder of the wider are area of the
land of Penny bage Road is currently
vacant and is used informally as car
parking theid is not a designated
Council car parking nor is it managed as
such it is utilized for this use in the
absence of any other formal use whilst
it's recognized that the development of
this part of the site will result in
less area of the site for car parking
and this is not the formal car park for
Trafford FC or any other local uses in
the area which do not benefit from their
own car parking areas so to conclude
offices of secure SC significant
amendments to this proposal um
originally and following the defal in
relation to the sighting scale massing
and appearance of the development the
proposed development remains however
perpendicular to the existing Terrace at
Shore View which is is somewhat at odds
with the open grain of the area and
whilst extensive Landscaping is proposed
to prevent the visual impact of the
development substantial weight is
attached to this home however this is
balanced against the very substantial
weight which is important to the
delivery of the greatly needed
affordable homes specifically for those
who are
homeless the Tilted balances engage and
in line with the mppf it is considered
that the as adverse impacts of granting
this permission would not significantly
and demonstr outweigh the benefits it's
also noted that since the application
was first considered by members in
August
2023 positive changes have been made to
the sighting and de and design which
lessen the harm in design terms and
reduce the impact of the development on
the res residents of shv terce this
further tips upon imbalance in favor of
the
application and whilst there are some
policy conflicts the scheme is
considered to comply with the
development as a whole and the
application is therefore recommended for
approval with conditions thank
you thank you m Lo have speakers on this
item um Miss Smith Council Thomas if you
decide which one of you would to speak
first counc
Thomas you know you'll get five minutes
to speak time beginning watch you press
the microphone thank you
coun thank you
chair the main objection from myself of
the initial committee to this
application is still SP I did not think
that the consultation process for many
months would have brought forward dis
Amendment um attempting to sa board when
he goes further than the original L grab
uh from the last application
there are over 60 parking spaces not 40
on being lost on this car park I say car
park because it has prescribed rights it
has been a parking facility for overuse
it signed by traffic Council until I
found out that the time was not now
three months ago and replaced by traffic
Council this raises the need to change
of use change of use application prior
to or included in uh this application
which is is not to help them prescribe
right the government
continues use as of right by or on
behalf of and against Freeholder owners
for a period of at least 20 years and
must set out the use and enjoyment
relied upon to substantiate the claim
this has been managed in the car for
over 30 years SP SPD 1.1.1 determines a
development impacts on infrastructure
and creates a need for additional or
improved community services and
Facilities without wasting development
could have an adverse effect on social
econom social economic or environmental
terms the residents at 22 to 28 minimum
sh view will have access to the front
entrance of their Gardens removed by the
pick fence Green Space the pl show the
private pathway for for sh view runs
long that fence it doesn't is set at 1.5
MERS into the properties owned by the
residents this cils least of four homes
from direct access to the front Gardens
the new new application does not meet
SBG that states distances to rear Garden
boundaries from Main Windows should be
at least 10.5 M for two story Flats the
boundary to sh Hall residential I
residential hle home is less than 9
meters in fact as wall to wall not to
the boundary of the rear Garden the car
home is a single story building and has
no facade to offer protection this
clearly impes on people in the
residential homes rights and privacy
with direct window views from both
floors of the application directly into
the windows of the home to accommodate
residents with mental health issues also
policy L 7.3 of the traffic course
strategy states that the development
must not Prejudice the immunity of
future occupants of the development and
or occupance of adjacent Properties by
reason of overbearing overshadowing
overlooking or visual intrusion noise
and or disturbance odor Al s is
considered to be up toate and for
decision making purposes and full we can
be attached to it the use of tilted
balance which is basically paragraph 11
of the mpf is wrong because of the
boundary distances and any he says
anyway any adverse impacts on gr
commission would sit with significantly
demonstr our way benefits on assess
against policies in this framework Tak
as whole he been shown the initial
meeting the immunity road safety and
Community imity will begin on this
damage Sorry by this development 200
meters from Park and already over
subscribed Road parking in the area with
zero control Crossings across chass road
yet the junction of chassen Road and
Shore Road just 100 meters from the
proposals is considered such an accident
black spot that um traffic cling
measures were put in place to combat
speed on CH Road I strongly point to the
submissions of the concerns of trap FC a
club that has invested into the local
area and our excellent neighbors per
former William Ro golf club which is
nearing fields in trust status has not
even been included in the ecological
survey this coupled with the force
Landscaping tag and quote obtrusive
design appearance stated by the officer
offers further reasons to refuse finally
the consultation short residency scheme
offered homes for people in hospitals
that would be vetted before offered a
tency the application includes for a bed
for the night rough sleepers multiperson
residency and a is the case the locality
of the burning hand and the already
police reported use of car the car park
for uh drug dealing to take place makes
it even more unsuitable I'm aware of a
complaint that he going to the director
of place Council and uh this week
regarding the consultation and the 500
name plus um petition that was delivered
to the council prior to the uh
application being put in uh but has been
unable to be heard as yet due to uh
the AGM and subsequent meetings the
purpose of the scheme though required
nationally has no bearing on the
planning decision you make and it was
alluded to at the previous meeting that
if this was a private Constructor it
would not reach committee stage that
statement still stands and I ask the
application refuse on the grounds he
does not meet SBG or the core strategy
thank you thank you
Council m in
your s apply for you except you get
three minutes to speak W you press the
microphone Ellie Smith owner of 26 sh
I'm objecting on behalf of the community
shw view residents and traffic football
club I reiterate the objections voiced
in August related to Traffic Safety
impact on residents and the consultation
process is still standing given the
relatively arbitrary adjustments made to
the plan since then appr previous quote
from councilor Lawrence Walsh remains
highly relevant to the application being
discussed today if this application
wasn't talking about homeless
accommodation and this was a normal
private planning application it would
not last two seconds in the normal
planning committee we would throw it out
the following objections are now in
addition the plan still failed to align
with the historic Urban grain of shorby
cottages despite some minor adjustments
the development does not maximize
opportunities to enhance the area's
character and quality relying heavily on
Landscaping to mitigate it contrived
appearance a setback of 9 and a half
meters from The Cottages remains in
reality insufficient failing to create a
genuinely meaningful separation from
established dwellings a peaceful and
quiet community enjoyed as such for over
140 years the 7 and a half met sight
boundary to our front doors poses a
significant impact on the privacy of
much used south facing front Gardens of
five homes it is our right to Peaceful
enjoyment of our property the plans are
now closer to the residential home
disrupting the communal G and privacy so
important to the vulnerable adults
living there when newly proposed traffic
access and turning points are considered
outside the home the impact of the
safety of the residents would be severe
the site is not specifically allocated
for residential development nor nor
identified in our tbr's land register
considered suitable as such so again I
ask why is this development to be an
exception to any other application
private or otherwise the highways
officer deflected our objection away
from the loss of car parking immunity in
August me meeting by the reason that it
does not have a parking order this is a
mood Point as the car park is used
freely for this purpose and without
civil enforcement of any kind Council
Land by law is considered public land
and its purpose is to serve the Public's
benefit and safety evidence shows the
uninterrupted use of this land as a car
park for well over 27 years therefore
prescribed rights must be applied the
plans now further reduce the number of
parking spaces with a loss of 68 overall
well over a third of the car park at
realistic safe capacity
the council has also installed and
maintained signage designating the land
as a car for public use suggesting its
recognition as such We are continuing to
demonstrate viable objections a massive
loss of residential and Community
imunity Clements to private and
residential homes in relation to the
plans that have been revised
detrimentally all planning reasons to
reject the Tilted balance exists for
reasons to protect both the applicant
and the community however are many
objections and concerns have been
repeatedly ignored and discarded a 500
strong petition gathered from the ENT
area as well as a lack of fair
engagement with us during the
consultation process this community
cannot reasonably accommodate this plan
without significant detriment we implore
the committee to reject this application
on the basis of a tilted balance
demonstrating that the negative impact
on a wellestablished community greatly
outweighs the benefit to 12 individuals
thank you thank you
Mr we have and
councel
first the prev speakers you get three
minutes
from thank you chair Rachel Conor from
MOS Vincent statement in support of the
application thank you for the time for
reconsidering this micophone actually
on again Rachel Vincent state support of
the application thank you for your time
reconsidering the important application
and by way of reminder the scheme
proposed will provide much needed
accommodation for those who have been
made homeless or experienced rust
sleeping in traford and are looking to
take their next step towards independent
living and a permanent
tendency this proposal presents the only
viable opportunity currently available
to deliver this type of accommodation in
Trafford a great deal of work has been
put in by a range of agencies and
organizations to assess the options this
proposal being considered the best
opportunity to deliver a scheme to meet
this housing need in Trafford the scheme
is supported by an allocation of funding
from the Department of leveling up and
housing and communities to deliver the
project in addition to providing high
quality accommodation for residents who
are in truly need in true housing need
this accommodation will also enable the
council to house residents at a lower
cost than other less suitable temporary
accommodation providing a financial
benefit to the council at a time when
local local Authority finances around
the stay from the outset msv has engaged
proactively with stakeholders to evolve
the scheme design in order to deliver
the scheme the layout alone for this
project has seen a number of iterations
which reflects the degree to which we've
engaged listened and acted on matters
raised throughout the planning process
since the planning committee of the 10th
of August we have specifically made a
number of amendments to address the
concerns raised during the committee
these include the relocation of the
building moving this further south to
increase the standoff distance to Shore
View this has required significant
engagement with the council's Estates
team and both parties have engage
positively to arrive at an improved
location for the building alongside this
The increased standoff distance from sh
view has enabled us to create a larger
landscape buffer to the northern part of
site this will soften the impact of the
development and address concerns
relating to visual impact and the impact
from the scheme on the urban grain and
any potential Heritage matters
floor plans for the scheme have been
amended to address the points raised in
respect of the elevations and the
arrangements of doorways this further
draws on the design esos from sh field
terce which stakeholders felt should be
reflected in the scheme the ground floor
units on the scheme will now be designed
to m42 standards which will make them
more accessible and
adaptable we've also received some
questions over the last couple of days
regarding construction management
matters including uh questions regarding
arrangements for the delivery of
materials and parking for contractors we
would like to reassure the committee
that if planning is granted MSB will
engage a contractor to prepare a robust
construction Environmental Management
plan and that we are satisfied for a
condition to be placed on the planning
consent but no construction works are to
take place until the council has
considered and approved this plan we now
believe that the proposals put forward
today represent an excellent opportunity
for the council to take an important
step forward to securing new and vital
homelessness accommodation within the B
could just wrap up now we trust that the
committee can see that MSP is engage
positively and passionately with the
stakeholders to deliver the best
possible scheme and we remain committed
in working with the stakeholders
throughout the process and Beyond and I
therefore ask that the committee
supports this application thank you
thank
you
s rul apply your time will begin once
you press the Buton on the
microphone good evening thank you chair
and committee for allowing me the
opportunity to address you in support of
this application I have been involved in
this proposal since its Inception
attending the public meeting earlier
this year and keeping a breast of the
objections support and design changes of
the scheme in a personal capacity I know
this site well I listened to the last
debate of planning committee and
acknowledge the challenges raised by
members here so I am pleased therefore
that the scheme presented tonight is a
revised and much improved one I can see
this is reflected in the officers report
which states these design improvements
less than the previously identified harm
and tilt the balance further in favor of
the proposals the building has moved
further away from existing properties on
Shore View the external design of the
buildings has been improved private and
communal immunity space increased the
landscaping and Boundary treatment offer
upgrades
an area for parking which could
accommodate over 100 cars is still
retained it has been some years since I
served on the planning committee but my
but that experience allows me to
recognize that this like most all
applications call on balanced decision
making I understand this application has
generated concerns some of which are
shared with by planners all of which are
set out in the office's report I am
confident that everyone who has wanted
to contribute their views has had an
opportunity to do so objections received
however need to be balanced against the
many positive aspects and outcomes of
this proposal in Trafford we Face a
housing crisis one exacerbated by Rising
private rents and a lack of social and
affordable rented homes as a local
Authority we have a duty to support our
residents who become homeless so it is
right that we look to our land assets to
provide this type of much needed
accommodation in the burrow we currently
have 8,600 84 households on our waiting
lists housing waiting lists in Trafford
we have 125 households in temperary
accommodation we have a further 72
households in bed and breakfast
accommodation the majority of which are
located out of burrow dedicated officers
within our housing teams have never
experienced a time when we have had such
a high number of households in this type
of temporary
accommodation within those hous in bed
and breakfast 46 are single people so
approving these 12 units today would
have a very real and positive impact
allowing people to move to much more
suitable accommodation and supporting
better long-term outcomes for them you
have heard many different views here
tonight I ask you to consider too when
weighing up your decision those whose
voices are rarely heard in any planning
or housing debate and that is the voice
of those in housing need thank
you
thank you Council before I open this the
debate the committee some comments from
the officers based on the um
contrib and then dis and address issues
raised
by traffic
particular that works thank
you I would like question
um sorry I would like some advice on the
legalities of the the 30 years and what
have you up because it's been raised by
a number of
speakers
this advice on me yeah um ownership the
land ownership point is um sort of
separate from the planning aspects of it
um and I believe the estate's department
been included in in the whole of the
negotiations of this
application um and Mr Evon has confirmed
that the area in question is not within
the parking orders that means it's not
designated parking place as such but um
I'll leave him to confirm
that you
thank you chair in in terms of in terms
of the corop the investigations we've
done in terms
of the actual land itself um we don't
have it registered on the as a traffic
regulation order as it is designated car
it's clearly been there for many years
now stat of that I'm legalities of that
whether you know there is a claim over
of use I I honestly can't answer that
question I can say that we don't have it
the as a part during the the life ear
part of the application we establish
from the car parking team that it's not
recognized as a car park from that
perspective and we can't find any orders
associated with that so in terms we see
it as a piece of land clearly owned by
the council for what purposes that land
is there for I honestly can't answer
that question because that's not my area
of expertise so in terms of looking at
the application we looked at the
application um and it's 12 minut one
bedroom and the nature of people who
were going to be using the site from
what we believe are unlikely to generate
a great deal Vehicles if if any in terms
of cars so in terms of additional
traffic
Associated purely with the development
we didn't see that it would have a sever
impact on the network locally it will
obviously lose some part some spaces on
the land without a doubt um as part of
the application survey was done at
during the football game yes it was
September 22 it's been around for a
while funny enough it's my local team
when I'm near the CH the
football that's irrelevant um but if the
demonstrate that through the period of
time the football match takes place and
this was in
September that there was the maximum of
cost part on the C were 10 102
Vehicles there would appear to be a
greater number than that if it was laid
out or it was set out and managed maybe
so that people par correctly it they're
not marked some people don't really
understand how they par but we also as
part of the application we did ask our
team in terms of traffic and complaints
and issues associated with surrounding
RADS and we're not to our knowledge
we're not aware of any specific requests
or any issues so on that basis given
that we didn't feel that it would
generate a great deal of extra cost
extra Vehicles we didn't feel that it
would have a serious or severe impact on
the network clearly the construction
traffic condition relating to that and
that's usually the case and that can be
managed through the process when they D
how they can get
into okay reassurance
M thank you okay on a couple of the
residential man points and then I'll go
to the t b um first of all there was a a
comment about access being
um access being blocked and the access
will remain as it is um presently there
shouldn't be any um impacts on access to
the Terrace um from um Shore Road or
from within the the penny heart Park
area and so just to clarify that point
um the separation distances um what
um SPD 4 talks about in terms of
Separation distances is is 15 M as a as
a minimum between a blank Gable which we
have here a blank Gable end and the and
any habit windows so um we have actually
24.5 MERS between the L G BL end and the
frontage of the um the properties on
Shore View so that's in compliance with
and sd4 and other was some talk about a
10.5 Meer distance to to boundaries
that's when you've got face inhabitable
Windows kind of like back to back you
know when you've got two Residential
Properties that back onto each other and
you've got two rear Gardens it's a 10.5
to to those boundaries where you've got
habitable Windows facing each other you
don't have that scenario in this case
because there's no habitable windows on
that side um elevation there and so
that's in that point also um in terms of
the impact on the care home that's
picked up in the officer report and
discussed in some details in um
paragraph
65 and the officers considered that
actually look back at the original floor
plans for the care home looking at the
uses of the rooms um adjacent to where
the development would be and what we can
what we can see is that there's no
habitable um room windows with on that
on that elevation that the the proposed
development would would impact on so
that's been considered and we don't
consider there would be any impact on
amenity for the care home there and
there would be a screen remaining for
the for the for the southern part of the
site as well so we're happy that there
there's no impact there in regards to
the use of the The Gardens and obviously
at the moment there's a car park joining
the site and um which is open to the
public and this number of comings and
going um so there's already a degree of
um um movement around um that that part
of the site um we will have clear
boundary with boundary treatment and
hedging so and no habitable windows that
would Overlook those rear Gardens and so
we're comfortable that there's there
limited impact on residential manity in
terms of overlooking overbearing or
pracy so moving on to the Tilted
balance and the application of the
Tilted balance and this is a housing
application and because the housing
policies in the core strategy are out of
date um paragraph 11 is engaged in the
Tilted balance applies so what that
means is that the the balance is already
tilted positively towards approving that
development so if you think about a set
of schedules you're already hanging over
towards a positive decision making point
and then you've got to think about those
harms and those um benefits and where
and when you put them onto the scales
which are already tilted slightly for
the development how that that that set
of scales then then um weighs and um in
the officer report and officers consider
that the the benefits and the the very
substantial weight that we've afforded
to the benefits of the scheme allow that
balance to tilt against those harms and
allow us to um recommend the application
for
okay thank you thank you M for that
reassurance uh would any member wish to
speak counc
Brown uh Antonio bran labor Council for
Asal Mery um I wish to speak in favor of
this uh development of 12 one bedroom
flats for social rent in my daily job I
worked as a hous professional for over
years
um because of that I've had uh I have
knowledge of and have worked with Moscow
St V on many occasions and I know them
to be a competent and experienced
registered provider of this type of
accommodation I have absolute
confidence in mare to
provide excellent management of the
scheme and to deal with any issues
competently and
efficiently the latest figures for
housing man in traffic as of theel
pointed out early show that there are
nearly 7,000 people waiting for social
housing in in the B of
traffic more than half of those people
are in what know those reasonable
preference categories to include
homeless also Council Tel point about
there currently 46 single people
ination
place there because there is
insufficient of contain temporary
comination in the
book this develop be a huge contribution
to addressing these
issues we have a
legal as well as a moral duty to those
people who find themselves
Hess in my opinion this Duty
outweighs the loss of soul on official
car park
spases the funding from hes in for this
development is time
limited and therefore implore members to
vote in favor of this
proposed is that a proposal you propose
that
we before we comes members are coming
next because that's you have expressed
lot a lot of my thoughts in what you
what you just said that because this is
quite this is a a s decision but I've
listened really closely to the views for
and against this development
particularly those of the of the
residents I understand the concerns
that's why we deferred this last time to
give the developer a chance to go away
and make some
improvements but as Council Patel says
as councilor Brian the local authorities
have a national Duty placed upon them to
provide housing with great emphasis on
building on Brownfield sites added to
which we've got a national
homelessness crisis which gives Trafford
a duty under its own policiy is to
reduce the of people in bed and
breakfast accommodation and 100%
affordable housing is a good way of
doing this and this scheme is affordable
housing on a brow field site which in
policy terms makes it fully line tra
Trafford programs and the scheme has
improved post we've heard the references
to this it's been moved 9.5 meters away
from the Terrace it's got improved
landscaping and the upgrade of
downstairs and the downstairs units have
been upgraded upgraded top to
accessibility but it's all balance and I
get it I totally get it there are still
some concerns of residents for example
parking and highways but it's been dealt
with extensively in the reports been de
with extensively by the officers here
tonight it's all been weighed very
carefully and I think the options are
made the correct recommendation so I
will be voting in favor of granting
this thank you uh counselor
B thank you CH I guess it's a difficult
one um and I can see you know the
emotions really you know for those who
have those who have spoken in favor of
it um you know on the parking Point um
I want to make a legal statement here
but you know if there is no legally
binding uh contract or agreement uh you
cannot enforce it I mean it may have
been used as a carart for a long time
but that's only probably a customary
sort of
arrangement I had reservation on that
but you know I'm satisfied now in terms
of the proposal which is on the table
now I can see the Improvement to the
layout itself I do however you know
problem with it and those who spoke
against it may not like it I think um
there is room for more you know units
there and you know perhaps the developer
should have looked into increasing the
number of units if
possible
and homelessness as we see on the report
and you know it's all over the media and
we see it you know firsthand on our
street I mean in my day job today I've
been approached by a couple of my
clients facing the homelessness issue
and you know the housing issue so
although I sympathize you know with the
residents you know their views that how
they may have you know an impact if it
goes further but I I totally get that
and I totally agree that this is one of
the best example of exercising you know
balancing here uh can also uh you know
make reference to the management plan
all the points raised you know in the
representations made or uh you know the
letters what the questions asked they're
all you know beautifully addressed
particularly you know the accessibility
and you know the adoptable dwellings so
so I think um we should you know should
be inviting all the members to consider
positively and I'm happy to second that
thank you thank you counc counc
jome thanks chair um I'm also going to
agree with the other members that have
spoken so far I think we've seen from
from our officers that this isn't a
desic native car park
um I know lots of residents feel there
should be prescribed rights but these
are all legal matters and matters so
aren't really planning issues so as a
committee I don't I don't think we can
really take on board the nature of the
land and the feeling that it should be a
car descried rights so I I think we
really have to view it as Brownfield
land um and all the other arguments
there are legal I think those that were
objecting especially councelor Thomas
spoke about it being Count Council land
and and reference the core strategy and
and said it should be used for community
and safety and well being ATT tra
residents but I think this is still the
case it's just that it's being used for
homeless people rather than cars
so I I kind of think that land is being
repurposed for a very very good reason
um and I think at the last committee I
did speak about some of the benefits of
this application if you look at the
ecological plan is a net gain of 10%
there's going to be 17 trees there's
also going to be an increase of th from
the last application um again if you
look at the um energy efficient design
um not many applications go as far as
this um and it would operate at 60%
lower carbon emissions and there' be 22%
reduced eny energy us usage that's quite
amazing for for an
application we don't get many that are
as good as that and we can see there
been allocated funds from from from the
Le leveling up from from the government
and I think these are being used for
really good purposes um and obviously
it's going to have a you know a good
effect on on homelessness and a positive
impact in that respect now I did vote
against this application last time
around but I did that because I felt the
Heritage aspects being
underplayed um but I think my fears have
been delayed due to the kind of
increased and and now what seems to me
to be ample separation
distances um I do think there might be a
problem from this being removed as a a
car part for Trafford SCC and I think as
the highways officer said you know they
could look at the remaining car par and
look at how the spaces are allocated
there maybe tidy that up a bit and I
have part there before as a football
fan um and I also think maybe the the
club could look at working with the
council to develop a traffic management
plan which kind of not only guides the
cars into that car park but maybe looks
at The Wider area and where fans can
park in the future but I think on the
balance of things I think this is a good
application and you know I'd be happy to
set thank you chair thank you counc
counc
proter thank you chair last time this
application came I asked could it be
deferred because it wasn't good
enough it's it's better and that
thankfully mosow and Vincent have
listened to us saying this is not good
enough and what we've got now
it could be even
better but it is better the distance
it's been moved away from sh view
matters I'm I'm no good at metric
but 9.5 M it's kind of that much isn't
it it's no less
more well there you go it's I think 100
cm is this thing it's better than it
was it's further away from those
beautiful homes of sh Terrace and that
it's now going to
be accessible downstairs that's
wonderful and I I'll say this until I'm
not on planning committee every single
home in traford that is built should be
built to those
standards and this is the second
application that we've had in recent
months that is being bu to those
standards and so I'll be supporting the
application thank you thank you coun
coun thank
you just I want to two question first
and I will come to my point but I speak
to C Thomas has raised SBG I don't know
what stands
for am I right sorry SBG what does it
stand ask those questions to the
[Music]
rather
appliation
appliation you have two questions first
question SPD for second question was
speak councilor Thomas referen SPG which
is a supplementary planning guide but I
believe he was referring to the
supplementary planning document number
four exactly yeah
I mean has improved a lot in compar to
last one when it came to AUST position
is very
clear traffic is very clear and there
are still 100 more so why should we
assuming for decades or 20 years 30
years it is a part it was not a part it
was just a land uh available to use for
the that they had a perception will they
be using for so it is clear and for me
around about 8,000 applications are in
the pipeline the people are waiting for
the homes and I've me as a conselor we
see many applications almost calls
people asking as homes homeless people
and about 72 coun Liz has mentioned 72
people on dead and great cost uh it is
very very alarming and uh
in Trafford and Trafford is the most I
me wor at the minute for regarding
social and this is more important
because these housings are going to be
built for homeless not all the homeless
but you know it is a very special case
for the people those
are special people you know I don't know
what the proper word I should use in
this Cas but I think it is very rare a
good application and a good Edition and
I fully support this application because
it covers all legal points thank you
thank you counc Council
ministers I think for me is a case of I
mean I think the car I mean debate about
the car park the car park is a car park
if it's been used one by as such for 30
years it is one however the loss of it a
lot of part of it I think given we have
got to balance I think the cas is the
case of there's more um good than harm
being made I think
that throne with the course of the
buildings and the fact that I'm much
more much happier with it having moved
further down effectively further away
from the properties um to to so I think
that theend the day this is a hell of a
lot better than what we what was
presented last time and yes we have got
of car park it is car park um but I
think that the the balance is that there
is more good down here so I will be I'll
be voting in support thank you thank you
councelor so been proposing seconded
that we approve this in line offic
recommendation can all those in favor of
that
IND
that that must been approved in L off
recommendation the next item on the
agenda
is
28 on
page
well
okay got some
[Applause]
time
okay MERS if we conate again we are now
moving to
the to the next item thank you chair
this application relates to a two-story
Terrace property located in the
residential area of Old Trafford cited
on the northeastern side Str with a rear
elevation facing on to CR Street plan
commission sought the demolition of the
original rear store and the erection of
a single story rear extension access r
no objections have been received and the
application has been refer to committee
at my discretion key issues the
consideration that we against the scheme
proposals desire an impact on
residential immed it is considered that
the proposal would result in a half full
overbearing impact in 29 sh Court's
habitable rear room window and a sense
of inclosure at the rear of property
that is materially more harmful than the
existing the proposed extension will
project 2.4 met further beyond the rear
elevation a rear window of this property
and would normally be considered
acceptable under SPD 4 guidance
it is also considered that the proposal
would appear overly dominant in the
street seene being excessively in scale
and taking up the whole of the rear
Garden area the ramp furthermore the
proposed design is departure from the
existing character of the street scene
which is considered to result in har the
and ATT trct from the established
character of the area however the
proposed development would provide an
accessible ground floor bedroom wet room
with step through access into the
bedroom from the rear of the The
Proposal would therefore provide an
enhanced living environment for a person
protective characteristic which is
considered to weigh in favor of the
proposal within the planning balance in
considering the planning balance
planning decisions need to be made
taking into account the public interest
rather than the private interest the
requirement is to make a decision in
accordance with the development plan
andless material considerations indicate
otherwise and in doing so apply the
public sector equality juices and
balance equality impacts with other
benefits and or harms arising for the
scheme in order to come to a decision of
public interest on balance officers
consider was there are benefits of the
proposal for the occupier and
improvements to accessibility the harm
to the street seene and residentially
mean to the neighboring property to
outweigh those benefits and the
application contri development plan
policy at spv4 it is therefore
recommended for
refusal thank you m co we have two
speakers on this tonight Council you
first you will get five minutes from
when you press the on the microphone
your
uh tonight I'm speaking in favor of the
proposed extension at 28 TR recort and
Al Trafford the officer recommendation
for this extension is to refuse it's a
long-standing case and where a previous
applications also been refused the
proposal is to demolish the current
store and build a single story extension
containing a bedroom and wet wet room
which covers most of the rear Garden
funding's been approved through a
disabled facilities Grant awarded to the
child in the family who has significant
disabilities the proposed adaptations
will see this child into and through
adulthood the family removed to this
property after becoming homeless in 2019
it was accepted that while the property
fulfilled their basic needs at the time
it would need significant adaptation as
the child grw and was no longer able to
be carried upstairs the process of
approving adaptation is so far taken
three years and the situation becomes
more urgent as time goes
on there are several reasons given for
recommending refusal firstly the design
is said to be are odds with the
character and appearance of the street
scene and the council has a duty to
protect the character and appearance of
individual properties and residential
areas the officer report says by reason
of its scale and design it would appear
overly dominant failing to appear as
subservient contrary to the prevailing
character of The Terrace row I've
submitted photos and we've seen photos
here of the streets of the committee
this is a densely built area of social
housing but I would say it's functional
rather than beautiful while the
extension would be visible I would argue
it's in no way detrimental to the
prevailing character of the street which
is dominated by Brick with very little
Greenery or particularly attractive
features you'll see from the final
submitted photo that I sent in that a
nearly identical extension has already
been built just a few yards away this
was approved in 2016 and class's
permitted development there's also
criticism of the plans in that along
with the access ramp or usable immunity
space at the rear of the property would
be removed B Storage issues as
specifically mentioned while the council
are Keen to promote active travel I fail
to see how the loss of bike storage is a
priority for a family who cannot even
leave a house without the proposed rant
this extension will be used to the
family's daughter for decades throughout
her lifetime and will no doubt be in
great demand should the family no longer
require the property the extension does
not reduce amenity it turns a house from
a prison into a home the extension is of
a substantial size so that it will serve
the child into our do Hood if this
extension is reduced it will no longer
be wheelchair
accessible there's further criticism in
that Natural Light Within the property B
will be reduced again I'd argue that the
purpose of this extension is for the fam
to be able to live safely and with
dignity a reduction in natural natural
lights at a small price to pay the
second reason given for recommendation
to refuse is the impact on the
neighboring property at 29 in response
i' say report having objected to the
proposal and it states that it would not
be overshadowed or overlooked as the
photos of the area show it's heavily
built up and this extension would not
significantly change the character of
neighboring properties many of the
current stores and sheds are built to a
similar
height the report acknowledges that the
proposal would provide an enhanced
living environment for a person with a
protected characteristic it however goes
on to say that the visual harm and
impact on residential immunity outweighs
the
benefits I would ask the committee to
really think hard about this judgment is
the visual appearance of this extension
so negative on this street it outweighs
the needs of a disabled child to live
with dignity and the simple immunity
that most of us are fortunate enough to
take for
granted 208 shes recort has been home to
the for four years they're settled with
children attending Local Schools the
grant for adaptations has been approved
if you refuse this application the
process of redesigning and resubmitting
will be costly both in terms of time and
finance to the the council and will make
life significantly more difficult for
the family refusing the application will
not make the family's difficulties go
away they will continue and life will
become
harder as you'll be aware there are very
very few ad adapted family-sized
properties in Trafford and there are
very many people waiting for them
urgently there are no easy alternative
options for this family who have
patiently waited for their approved
adaptations to begin the adaptation will
potentially be used by this family for
many years and could benefit other
families in similar desperate
situations I ask that you choose not to
follow officer recommendations and that
you support this disabled child to live
a dignified and functional life rather
than refuse a life-changing adaptation
on the basis the street scene of a
functional and unremarkable Street for a
house to be at home it needs to be
accessible safe and functioning for its
residents and tonight it's in your power
to change the life of this family here
with in this property thank you thank
you
councelor
get is that on yes can you hear
me okay thank you chair for allowing me
to speak briefly with regard to this
application in my Award of old
traford we find ourselves in the
paradoxical situation whereby a child
has been identified as requ iring a
major adaptation to their property in
order to thrive and flourish as they
grow up and this Council has awarded a
disabled facilities Grant to allow this
to happen yet the same Authority is
minded to refuse permission to allow
this to have to go ahead this is
absolutely
nonsensical there is no evidence that
this proposal would either disadvantage
or disturb neighbors indeed there are a
number of of other similar bills in the
neighborhood nor would it negatively
impact the Aesthetics of the street
scene or the environment and indeed no
objections to this development have been
received it would however make a world
of difference to a child with profound
disabilities and their family and allow
them to live a safe dignified and
comfortable family life which is what
any of us are reasonably entitled to
should you refuse to Grant this
application my question to you is what
would you reasonably and realistically
expect that this family does there are
no realistically realistic options
readily available in this bough as my
colleague has alluded to there are very
few adapted Family Properties and
particularly properties with four
bedrooms um to our knowledge we don't
know a single property that is available
in this B we've already heard
extensively about the housing crisis
within
traford it's taken this family three
years to get to this stage it is in your
gift to either keep a child and their
family in un suitable or inadequate
accommodation or allow a very modest
reasonable build to go ahead to which I
again highlight there has been no
objection which would be truly
transformation
and lifechanging for the child and their
family thank you I urge you to Grant
permission to this particular planning
request thank you thank you
councelor before I come to the ref
committee members
I the to this
um when when I went to see this and I've
read the objections and terms of the
impact on the street scenes and the lack
of um the lack of light in the to the
house next door first thing I noticed I
don't think it would have any kind of
detrimental effect on the street seat
and also given the layout of the rest of
the houses then um I don't think it
would be that detrimental to the in term
of loss of life like to the house houses
next door when you balance that um
against the massive Improvement in the
life it would have on the um of the
residents who are already there also the
fact the point made by councelor Taylor
that this is subject to a DFG based on
plans drawn up by the council's own
occupational therapists so I am going to
be proposing that we go against officer
recommendation on this and approve that
so many hand going up so it starts off
with you
councelor
you said everything I wanted to say
actually
chair um when I went to see this um I
just thought it was no brain you know it
needs to be done for this family and
looking at the house next door they've
got a screw room and the lights we've
got loads of light in that room I don't
think this this extension of this change
will make any difference to number
29 um and then as I'm leaving the area I
see just around the Cor corner almost
identical extensions being built and to
be honest I thought the this extension
actually improved the area um the visual
um impact of the area so
I to ref to go against the
refus I'm
I'm thanks chair I'm with you all the
way
except I don't think this this this is
this application I do not want to refuse
it this application but I don't think is
ready for approval
because I don't like the bin
Arrangements it's it's not identical to
the one around the corner the bins
actually go behind the house on that one
this the the solution in the reports is
to bring the bin have house the bins at
the front
that's a problem those that that court
and it is a court was
designed to have a central green area in
front it's not designed to have bins but
I don't think bins are so much of a
problem but it
should why I have a I always have a
problem with allowing something that
officers have prepared a refusal for
because it's not in the same sort of
Nick as an application that you would
expect if you were allowing it so we we
allow it no no conditions
whatever or we we follow the um
officer's approval I don't really want
to do uh disapproval I should say I
really don't want to do either this one
needs tweaking to in my mind to reach a
satisfactory approval stage I I'm sure
there is a solution that puts bins at
the
back it may even not be on the grounds
of the um the property the property is
not it's not a densely populated area
there it's got other Alternatives I
would like to work on that I don't know
whether I need to impose that right from
the start or impose it over completion
but I have a problem with putting bins
in an area even though it's gone it's
nowhere near the state it was when it
was originally designed as a cour I mean
it was meant to look like Midsummer it
doesn't now but I don't think we should
take that for granted that we can make
it worse by putting
bins on any of the houses at the front
these are front doors onto a grassy area
they shouldn't have things up the front
so that that's where I start so I don't
think it's I I mean I'm I'm really
looking for GU because I don't think
he's ready for um approval but I don't
want to support the
distri rejection yeah my only concern
was sending this back
for there is no alternative SC um this
is the scheme that's been drawn by the
inance the so we either approve it or
refuse it it's not going to get
changed
Che you can put conditions on that they
come up with a solution before it it is
approved on with a condition you can put
condition can I come back up because the
reason why approv the adaptations panel
where with rots and they normally come
up with three or four options on this
one they only came up with one which
means this is the absolute only one
which will suit the needs of the um of
the disabled person and if we send this
back to for another round it will take
far too long
iisten
coun thank you chair I don't want to go
into the debate about the bins I mean
it's a simple case of either we approve
it or you know I mean we go with the
officer's recommendation or we go
against on balance I mean it makes sense
that you know on this one we have to go
um in my view against the officer
recommendation but I don't know if there
is a precedent that has any in the past
has any member asked the officers that
you know after listening to so many
strong representation are they minded to
change their view about
it no no we we can't we can't do that
the the scheme is clearly contr to our
guidance and for consistency reasons
officers can only recommend this for
refusal that that's the position we're
in members can give a different VI
because they can give different weight
as they wish um but if we brought it
back we' bring it back again recommended
for refusal because we have to be
consistent on that in that case the the
development the proposed development is
based on you know professional advice
and the plan so on that basis you know
I'll Bey to Second for U recomend
against the recommendation
Council um the thing is I obviously I
can understand I can understand the
rules the officers have to follow they
do have set rules and we've had this
before haven't we with various things
with a um a nail s in a shed and things
in the past and we basically gone we get
that that the officers are restricted by
what rules they have and at the end of
the day that you know every situation
does not fit the rules and the rules
don't Su you know work for everything so
that's when it comes here and we go you
know what I think this needs to happen
so this is one of those isn't it it
clearly needs to happen the person needs
that accommodation I get I get them
might a problem with the bins but I mean
you know it's low this isn't it really
yeah it's a nice to have type thing so
um on the basis of that I think it would
be PR this um the go there the officer
that recommendation and and have it done
thank you thank you coun Council
proor than chair as Council M said this
is a
no-brainer it's a choice it's a simple
Choice do we say to the family of a
severely disabled
child well that's a shame but tough or
do we recognize
that without this this family's life
will be made harder everyone knows I had
to move from my poor story a guardian
house to a bungalow because I couldn't
do the stairs any longer I had the
financial capacity to do
that Bungalows cost a lot more than
houses not everyone does have this
is and I don't care where the bins go my
daughter's bins go at the front of her
house because there's no choice it's a
that's for the family to work out for
them briefly I'm not saying it's a big
issue what I'm saying is that planners
work on the assumption that something's
going to be refused they they draw up
the advice so they don't look at the
things that could make it better because
they're refusing in the first place
that's why I'm saying it could be
improved but I'm not against what you're
saying
and to just sum up um paragraphs 17 and
18 both say it is not considered there
would be any significant impact
overlooking impact on 29 shrewbury
that's 18 and it is therefore not
considered that the pro proposal would
have an unacceptable overbearing or
overshadowing impact on the immunity of
27 sh the houses either side they not
complain about it either our officers
have said there's no significant impact
of them
so sorry chair we have identified
harmful impa not in that paragraph We
have identifi har imp on 29 but not in
all not in all respects okay thank you
correction I I agree with everybody else
just spoken thank you councelor councel
Jerome thanks chair I won't speak too
long there probably not too much extra
to say but I do agree with Council
accordingly actually because it's not
only just where the positioning of the V
are it's where the am are compar to
collect so I think it will mean the res
to the
back public directed by for other
residents and that that's quite a task
and that would be in place not for just
the family that lives in now but for
future residents of of of the house and
I hear people say it's a no-brainer and
I hear councelor Taylor say it's
moderate and reasonable but it has been
refused for for a reason it does go
against our policies and we should take
that seriously but I think on the
balance of things hearing the special
reasons of those arguments I'm in the
same place as Council accordingly and
you know we'll vote for against of
recommendation on this book with
resolutions thank you chair thank you
councel Council Hassan thank
you I'm sorry I'm against the cil's uh
official recommendations and I my two
colleagues has
already uh explained very beautifully
and
comprehensively and uh I not talking
about the me is a all
issue we talking asking complaints every
single day about Amy
uh it is I mean we just only a minute
ago we passed an application approved
application for for the people and this
is a life of who is
disabled and the counil has given the
permission to build has given the
finance to build and and it is a long
life of future of a child who's going to
the same school just in a walking
distance and there is no complaint from
the
residents next doors there's no any
detrimental effects at all and and I
think we should uh go against off's
recommendation on compassionate on a
sympathetic grounds because it is a life
of a
child if he if we move the child from
that space he's living in the minut so
my my colleague has already mentioned
how badly affects the mental
health to the disabled people and so I
will will go against officers
recommendation I'm sorry and and and a
fully support my all colleagues those
who have already spoken in favor of this
uh against ofar of course uh my two
colleagues from Old Trafford they have
already given uh very strong uh
arguments and I will and I'm staying
with them because I I want to refuse
this application needs to approv and
going against the officer
recommendation thank you Council so we
propos the second is that we approve
this against offic of recommendation all
those in favor could the
indicate okay that we uh voted to
approve that against opposite
recommendation thank you sorry we just
do reasons and conditions is that okay
yeah thank you um we need to put a
statement of reasons on the on the file
um um lawfully so I've heard that you
are giving greater weight to the
particular circumstances of the occupant
of property uh and
um against the um the planning harms and
the conflict for the council's adoptive
policy and guidance is that
correct
those reasons
forus
again second reason a single
SC scale
desity would have no Dey overbearing
impact providing sense of inclosure we
don't think that's the case the reason
being because there's so many mixed
development at the re property there
isn't a common build
it's not they not all every single G
different actually been
improv so we don't think it will
have an impact
over thank you coun as said conditions
would just be the standard time limit um
materials to much and no no windows in
the two facing elevations on they can't
look into those two yards but they're
not shown anyway
so thank
you okay the final last one the agenda
is 11806 to George Street in on page 54
Pac and Miss L will the thank Miss
Lo thank you chair and this application
relates to the site which we're all
familiar with at um rackams department
store in alram and the junction of
George Street Stanford New Road Stanford
way within the Stanford quarter um
Shopping Center in alham um construction
works is significantly progressing on
the site pursuant to the most recent
Planning Commission and obviously
members will remember we had a similar
application at committee last month this
is a further minor material change to
the proposals and this time relating
specifically to the public realm and
Landscaping and to um change the wording
of the landscaping and cycle parking
condition I conditions and to compliance
worded conditions couple of photographs
of the site and the works that are on
goinging on the site at the
moment the changes relate to four
connected areas of public realm joining
the application site and the changes can
be seen in the images that we're showing
you now so we have a site part of the
site along George Street and then
Stanford Square and then dropping down
as the land levels change
and wrapping around Stanford new road
and then up along Stanford
way the specific changes um on the
George Street section relates to changes
in the hard landscaping materials the
seating and planting involving the
instruction removable Furniture changes
to the size of trees and the use of
shrub shrub
tubs hold on to your mou around but you
can see some images are on the on the
screen um on Stanford Square the
proposals here um again around the
materials used for the hard surfacing
the retention of the existing pagola
introduction of movable Furniture the
emission of one inground tree and then
the introduction of six smaller trees
and Planters on the Stanford new road
and part of the site and there's a
reduction in the extent of the paving
the introduction of a plinth to the
front of the building to form a seating
Edge and pl planter and the relocation
of the four trees to be planted in the
highway and moving that back from public
Highway into the private um land of the
application
site and then finally on Stanford way
which is the kind of functional and back
of house part of the um the public realm
and there's an emission of um a small
pocket park on the South Station House
car park and then consequent changes to
the public realm around that so parts of
Stanford W including the relocation of
trees and the size there's also
admission of trees and areas of planting
on the Northern and part of Sanford W
for the revised saving servicing
strategy um the main rational and
reasoning for these changes is to ensure
that there is a comprehensive um
strategy across public realm which
follows that of already the already
implemented public realm improvements
within altringham to make sure that we
have this consistency throughout um um
throughout the town center and overall
the changes would not fundamentally Al
to the development as previously
approved and would still result in an
overall Improvement to the public realm
and levels of green infrastructure when
can compared to the current situation
where there isn't there isn't any the
level of harm previously identified to
Heritage assets is unchanged and it's
considered that the amended proposals
would not result in any new adverse
impacts subject to appropriate
conditions and as a result the
conclusions reached on the planning
balance under the previous application
and remain unchanged the application is
recommended for approval and is subject
to appropriate conditions thank
you thank M Lo any wish to
speak on this one I think I'm going to
propose that we approve it as for the
officer's recommendation it's an
improvement of an existing development
so I'm happy to uh move it for approve
any thanks chair um
in this actual space I think we're
seeing the removal of The Secret Garden
at the moment so it's good to see these
fans moving into bace creating the kind
of landscaping and design that will make
people want to come to that area of the
Town Center obviously alongside the
development of the r building itself so
yeah I think the improvements are great
and it' be great for the town center and
again it keep me from people the
different parts of
the and hopefully keep you coming back
so thanks J uh thank you Council yeah
I'm hely in favor of the whole
development of Geor Street and this
improved on what was what was the the
previous plans councilors if you
approves on the on the previous plans um
so it's being proposed and seconded that
we approve this recommendation all those
in favor please
indicate that in line with off
recommendation we have business business
okay the meeting is now closed thank you
members
that